in your french you said you had a
painful memory connected to one line
that was
was that against yeah that was the one
that was the one
and his body language so important in
chess yeah it is important
but it is not uh the defining factor it
is just important
combined with other factors 92 i'm
playing c5
c3 yeah this is um
[Music]
i didn't cover that move but it's
yeah it was even recommended in some
book i should have covered it but it's
not a good move i think
it was recommended in one book you know
some kind of book that was called i just
now remember
yeah i should have covered it
it's not a great move though
something like destroy the french or
whatever some book very weird
very weird like they recommend this line
against the french
very strange never seen this line
before that book and after that book but
that book recommends it
very weird line just white creates an
isolated pawn
for no reason at all
knight f6 i'm not sure but i think it's
okay if he takes i take and i will give
bishop before check
and as we trade more pieces i think i'm
doing fine
somebody says body mass index
do you have a healthy bmi um
i am definitely on the low side of it
like uh
i'm on the underweight side of it but i
think i am
okay like healthier yeah i mean i'm
healthy yes like
i don't have i don't have health issues
but i am i have a low um
like i'm a i'll say
less than average my weight is
lower than average definitely but
not to the extent that i have any health
issues definitely not
have a pretty low body fat
when you are when you have such low body
fat like i do i think it
could be a problem if you get like um
if you get like
very ill or something and then you'll
keep losing the weight then it could be
a
problem
but as i have right now it's not an
issue so don't worry don't worry about
my bmi
have you considered bulking up a little
bit
[Music]
yeah i think i'm doing uh fine i'm doing
fine i had
before the before the gyms were
closed i was going to the gyms for
um yeah different periods but i was
attending the gym
quite a bit in some of these periods but
i think the
the thing that i have realized when it
comes to my
weight it was very hard to gain weight
um while remain
well um while remaining um
um how to say
while still feeling good so let's say i
would have to eat like way too much
to gain weight it has to do with my
uh
what is it called metabolism
the metabolism is very fast so i
actually eat quite a lot
well not not a lot but like i ate normal
and i can even more but like the
the metabolism the speed
with which the body burns these calories
is pretty fast
so currently i don't gain much weight
but i think as people age
these things slow down and eventually i
will gain a little bit more weight so
don't worry
supplements help yeah but why would i
need uh why would i need it
what for as i already told you i'm
feeling very healthy
i'm in a very uh very
good shape i
have a pretty fine stamina and
don't experience any issues connected to
that
so yeah we can keep talking about my uh
bmi or other health concerns that you
have for me
but i think we had dealt with the topic
successfully